you don't have to do anything more than
you're capable of you know like just
believe in yourself mate like you belong
at this level and I don't even think
about it because I'm surrounded by these
guys right you know at this level the
best of the best and I've really never
known any different it was the same in
every sport that I've done you know I've
always been surrounded by by the best
guys and uh
they've always thought like you know a
player that makes the team great can be
is as valuable as a great player
um and and I've always I always in
rowing want to be the worst guy on the
boat because that meant that everyone
had to be better than me so then we had
a great crew and and save me on this I
love being number 30 because the harder
I train the better I am better at 29 29
other guys have to be